[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono un hacker unitica Lakers Ma chi
sono gli hacker Cosa sono gli hacker
cosa fanno molti di voi potranno
assimilare Lakers a il Bad Guy la
persona cattiva magari Alcune hanno
visto Mr robot Magari altri no Comunque
con le persone magari col cappuccio il
Black Cat che viene chiamato
o magari altri lo simileranno al crimino
organizzato il cybercrime Appunto Quindi
questi criminali in questi gruppi di
criminali questi gang di criminali che
sono pagati per entrare nei vostri
computer rubarvi i dati al conto
corrente
prendevi di Mira essere cattivi In
verità oggi vorrò dirvi che sono qua
dirvi che magari non è sempre così
magari c'è anche un'altra faccia da
leggings In verità il termine
deriva dal verbo to Hack che in inglese
vuol dire prendere per esempio un tronco
di legno e ricavare dei pezzetti di
legno da accendere il fuoco Quindi per
quelli magari che sono appassionati di
motori Anche il Tuning quindi modificare
qualcosa allo scopo di
rendere utile è sempre stato un po'
nella nel DNA delle persone nel nostro
DNA quello di creare qualcosa
è questo quello che è appunto a Ranking
e
Lloyd nel nel 1986 ha scritto quello che
poi divenne il manifesto della King
quello che è stato una pietra
del nostro movimento un po' ricalca un
po' la filosofia che c'è dietro la
comunità degli hacker questo primo
manifesto è stato
pubblicato quando lui è stato incarnato
per aver commesso i primi crimini
informatici ancora Back in the Days è
diventato subito virale famosissimo al
punto che anche nel film di marzukenberg
e social network nel dormitorio dove lui
dorme c'ha peso al muro questo questo
manifesto andiamo un po' guardare cosa
c'è in questo manifesto lui parte dice
Guardate io sono sempre stato un bambino
un po' nerd un po' goffo a scuola Magari
non ero il più belloccio del gruppo però
ero molto intelligente e da un lato
questa intelligenza mi faceva
capire che già mi annoiava Cioè mi
annoiavo a scuola e poi non mi piaceva
stare in un ambiente con delle regole
sociali definite dalla scuola stessa al
fatto che il professore ha il suo il suo
programma da fare deve seguire il
programma Io volevo fare altro e per lui
c'è stata una grande svolta quando ha
appunto
un contratto se vogliamo il suo best
friends che era il suo computer no
Quindi ha scoperto il computer perché il
computer faceva quello che diceva lui
Cioè non lo giudicava non perché non era
un belloccio non era magari abile a
parlare allora venivo giudicato e poi il
computer era onesto con lui Cioè se lui
sbagliava era problemi suoi Cioè nel
senso è lui che programma il compito
amministrazione sbaglia è un suo
problema e inoltre il computer gli
permetteva di comunicare con altri
simili in attraverso queste prime reti
primordiali l'internet per quelli che
non sono così giorni si ricordavano come
era l'internet all'epoca proprio molto
mi piace e questo computer funzionava da
proxy vuol dire che tu comunichi con una
persona senza sapere se questa persona
cioè come è fatta questa persona come
quando guidiamo la macchina la macchina
è un po' un un proxy un muro Quindi non
sappiamo se dall'altra parte sta
guidando una persona che c'ha un certo
colore di pelle o fare una certa lingua
quindi davanti al computer Siamo siamo
siamo tutti uguali e lui dice una cosa
interessante dice guarda io ehm
attraverso il computer posso esprimere
la mia curiosità per me è il tool il
meccanismo con cui riesco a esprimermi
come persona e anche se voi mi avete
incarcerato e probabilmente io sì io ho
commesso magari del crimine ma il mio
vero crimine è la curiosità
Questo è un po' il punto di partenza di
quello che vogliamo di quello che
vogliamo dire oggi questi primi hacker
negli anni 80 hanno iniziato a
connettersi appunto attraverso questo
Inter primordiale in quelle che vengono
chiamati interraci quindi delle chat in
internet per comunicare e iniziavano a
creare le prime leggings questi questi
gruppi virtuali se volete che
condividevano informazioni partendo
dalla curiosità che avevano di scoprire
il mondo e non era solo un incontro
virtuale ma era anche un incontro fisico
Questa è una foto che ho preso io stesso
in alcuni di questi
Reunion che facciamo che si chiamano
ecmeeting che ci sono anche in Italia
una volta all'anno e l'idea è proprio
quella di incontrarsi e di scambiare con
gli altri la propria curiosità spesso
questi incontri vengono fatti i luoghi
sociali Magari autogestiti dove A
differenza della scuola o comunque in
sistemi dove ci sono delle regole Quali
regole sono create della comunità stessa
quindi siamo tutti uguali e siamo noi
stesso che creiamo queste queste regole
e ci creiamo le nostre stesse dinamiche
in questi eventi vengono tenuti i corsi
training a un momento di scambio di
informazioni ci sono dei corsi anche
ovviamente di intesi come dice di
hacking Per esempio questo è un un set
di lockpicking che permette di aprire
lucchetti questi Lucchetti possono
essere fisici come in questo caso o
possono essere virtuali i lucchetti
Appunto cibernetici
con le stesse comunità si incontrano
regolarmente anche a dei Camp molto più
grandi Questa è una foto che
ho preso al CCC di Berlino anni fa
questo è un meeting di hackers che si
svolge quattro anni in Germania in
questo caso in un aeroporto abbandonato
e periferia di Berlino Quindi potete
immaginare tutti questi appassionati che
partono con i loro Van con
i propri computer ma anche non so il
cibo la propria cultura e si incontrano
e spendono cinque giorni assieme in
questo camping scambiando informazioni e
divertendosi perché fondamentalmente è
quello che facciamo è divertimento nel
senso
come si dice
e questi primi gruppi che magari
all'epoca potevano essere come ho detto
un po' black quindi appunto assomigliare
al personaggio che mi ha visto
all'inizio della presentazione hanno
iniziato a avere un un
una visibilità pubblica e si può dare
come data di partenza il 1998 in cui i
Loft che erano una grande Action Group
negli States a testimoniato davanti al
congresso americano dicendo e Guys
Internet è fondamentalmente Broken Non a
caso Internet è nato da dei laboratori
non era stato studiato per andare su una
Global skill come come tuttora no e
molti di questi di questi hackers
soprattutto quello in centro ha iniziato
ha iniziato a lavorare con il governo
quindi
la pubblica amministrazione ma anche le
grosse Corporate hanno iniziato a dire
Ehi però questi ragazzi alla fine fanno
qualcosa di utile No comunque ci
mostrano che internet è rotto e
attraverso
una collaborazione con loro possiamo
aiutare a migliorare appunto la rete
migliorare il nostro il nostro sistema e
così sono nato una serie di iniziative
per poter utilizzare appunto la
conoscenza di questi di questi
scienziati se vogliamo chiamare di
questi ricercatori uno di queste è il
capture of Flag è una competizione che
si svolge tutti gli anni in questo caso
a defcon che è una conferenza che c'è a
Las Vegas ad agosto e l'idea di
richiamare i migliori eaker Se volete li
voglio mondiali in modo che
combattono tra di loro cioè l'obiettivo
è quello di entrare nei sistemi degli
altri E difendere il proprio come una
specie di Olimpiadi se volete no
dell'informatica in Italia Non siamo di
meno abbiamo una squadra che si chiama
maccheroni che riunisce i
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e riunisce i migliori i migliori le
migliori menti dei vari universita No da
Tor Vergata Roma a Politecnico di Milano
o molte altre università e tutti gli
anni si gioca cioè si va si va a Vegas e
si spende tre giorni nel contest
ovviamente ci sono anche ricchi premi e
quant'altro quindi questa è una delle
multi iniziative un'altra iniziativa è
il Pont pone in inglese vuol dire
trovare una vulnerata in un sistema e
espletare questo sistema entra nel
sistema in questo caso
un sistema Allora Vinci Anche no e vengo
preso un target quale potrebbe essere la
Tesla e si dice ok 50.000 dollari sul
piatto Se riesci a bucarmi la testa e
come vedete qua nel video
macchine moderne hanno un sistema di
comunicazione remoto Quindi se c'è una
vulnerabilità in molte le macchine che
ci sono adesso qua tutte quelle che sono
adesso hanno la SIM Car integrata si
riesce a avere accesso alla macchina
quindi in questo
il cofano davanti ci dovrebbe essere le
valigie quindi si può rubare tutto e
quant'altro
e chiaramente questi questi hacker che
adesso sono diventati etica Lakers
sono
all'attenzione di tutti anche delle Big
Corporation Microsoft l'anno scorso nel
Fiscal dell'anno scorso ha stimato aver
messo almeno 13 milioni di dollari sul
piatto per poter fare
awarding di più di 300 ricercatori e
Apple ha pagato più di un milione di
dollari per una singola vulnerabilità
quella che si chiama full Chain exploit
quindi io ti mando un sms o messaggi di
posta o messaggi WhatsApp telegram
Facebook quello che volete voi lo Aprite
io o controllo completo del vostro del
vostro apparato quindi capite benissimo
il rischio di questo tipo di
vulnerabilità che è una Cyber weapon
fondamentalmente quindi Apple dice ok io
ti pago milioni di dollari così ventila
vulnerabilità a me Apple che la peggio
la risolvo prima che diventa pubblica o
prima che tu la vendi al Cyber Crime
organizzato al Dark web ok
quindi l'idea Appunto quello di pagare
questi ricercatori in modo che la
vulnerarietà viene fissata viene risolta
prima che ti venga pubblica e qualcuno
la sfrutta perché se ho accesso una
vulnerabilità del genere io come
attaccante cioè che sono qua la sinistra
posso inoculare un malware un virus
all'interno del tuo cellulare a quel
punto rubare tutte le informazioni che
avete che hai sul cellulare non so le
foto i contatti i messaggi WhatsApp
posso anche attivamente prendere
controllo del cellulare attivando per
esempio il microfono in modo posso
ascoltare cosa succede attivando la
webcam del cellulare vedere dove sei e
quant'altro tutto questo ovviamente è
possibile se si scoprono metà di questo
tipo quindi meglio che ci sono
iniziative in cui questi ricercatori
vengono pagati e lavorano per per il
bene comune in questo caso altri
ricercatori etica Lakers hanno lavorato
con CBC in Canada per mostrare come le
telecamere di sorveglianza questo povero
cristo aveva appena comprato contenevano
vulnerabilità che
permettevano ai criminali appunto di di
spiare la sua vita personale cioè tutte
le sue telecamere fondamentalmente
mandavano
lo String video pubblico
fondamentalmente su internet quindi
potete capire se un criminale ha accesso
a tutte queste informazioni può sapere
quando uscite da casa Quando entrate
dove andate Cosa può fare può non so
ricattarvi dicendo io mi paghi tot cioè
io rilascio tutte queste bellissime
video di casa tua pubblici su internet o
posso sapere quando uscite di casa e
quindi a quel punto entro attraverso il
tool di lockpicking fatto vedere prima
scassino a casa vostra e il gioco è
fatto quindi molti dei dispositivi che
abbiamo a casa adesso che sono smart
quelli degli Smart device Io sono tipo
la smart TV 8 quello che è Smart
toilette ormai vedono tutto spesso
contengono software vecchio Legacy
software quindi meno male che ci sono
appunto questi etica Lakers che studiano
questi software questi sistemi Prima che
qualcuno ne abusi in quest'altro esempio
è che abbastanza interessante c'è Andy
Grinder che è un giornalista di Forbes
che ha lavorato con due mitica Lakers
che hanno studiato appunto come vedete
già qua potete capire cosa succederà
hanno studiato appunto i problemi
appunto di queste nuove vetture tipo la
testa che mi ha vinto che abbiamo visto
prima e questi etica Lakers sono seduti
cioè dall'altra parte del mondo
fondamentalmente e lui tanto sta
guidando e li fanno tutti gli scherzi
del caso quindi accendono tirano sul
volume a manetta Infatti abbassato Cioè
non lo tergicristalli piuttosto che
fanno partire l'aria condizionata al
massimo e quello che è ma peggio ancora
arriva il punto che vedete adesso in cui
decidono volontariamente di intervenire
sulla centralina del motore quindi di
spegnere i giri del motore quindi lui è
tipo in autostrada 130 all'ora e la
macchina Ovviamente si ferma
fondamentalmente la costa in prima
corsia quattro frecce panico e lui
chiama super irritato e fa Eh ragazzi
cioè Va bene ok però Fatemelo ripartire
gli fanno Guarda devi proprio spegnere
la macchina e riaccenderla perché non
abbiamo neanche modo di fartela
ripartire quindi
capite bene appunto la serietà e i
problemi che ci possono essere
relativamente un mondo della privacy noi
stessi Lavoriamo in questo campo Io ho
iniziato all'epoca come Beh credo
e adesso ovviamente mi occupo di ricerca
il nostro compito Appunto È quello di
aiutare tutti voi e quant'altro per
avere un sistema più sicuro tanti anni
fa abbiamo presentato per esempio quella
lompori Malesia come possibile dirottare
potenzialmente una nave grazie ai primi
che hanno delle nuove i radar ristoranti
sulle nuove navi qualche anno fa abbiamo
lavorato sui nel campo delle
applicazioni radio industriali mostrando
com'è possibile prendere controllo di
una gru o gli altri apparecchi
industriali
comunicano anche questi via onde radio è
molto Scary anche questo scenario in cui
qualche anno fa hanno richiamato il
mercato più di 500.000 pacemaker perché
questi pacemaker potevano essere
aggiornati remotamente Quindi tu vai dal
medico il medico ti fa l'aggiornamento
remoto via onde radio chiaramente c'era
un problema e quindi anche lì era
possibile attaccare un metro in mano era
un virus all'interno del pacemaker e
quindi avere controllo totale su quello
che faceva il pacemaker quindi cambiare
la frequenza del cuore o potete
immaginare gli scenari e ovviamente
tutti i costi perché quando devo
richiamare 500 mila installazione non è
che cambiare un pacemaker a 500.000
pazienti se è una cosa che si fa così su
due dita
Spero di avervi convinto un po' del
fatto che questi questi haker che per
molti sono considerati dei criminali dei
Bad Guys e dobbiamo stare alla larga con
diventano invece prendono un ruolo di
Scienziati un nuovo di ricercatori che
morsi dalla curiosità vogliono fare il
Next step quindi andare oltre e cercare
appunto di fare un lavoro che aiuti al
sistema cumula sistema e alla comunità
Quindi d'ora in poi guardateci con occhi
diversi grazie
[Applauso]